Disney's live-action Aladdin dives much
deeper into Jasmine's backstory
revealing the dark history of the young
princess's mother and some hidden clues
as to who was responsible for her
untimely death
yippee-ki-yay movie lovers I'm John and
in this video I'm revealing the secret
truth about Jasmine's mum and Jafar's
nefarious connection to her past there
will be a few spoilers for jasmine and
Jafar's backstory so just be aware if
you haven't seen the film yet and don't
forget my aladdin giveaway is also
running so be sure to subscribe and
leave a comment for your chance to win
the live-action version of Aladdin
modifies a number of things about the
story in Disney's original animation the
crucial change for what were discussing
here is the conversation between jasmine
and Aladdin when they first meet Aladdin
says the princess should get out of the
palace more as the people haven't seen
her in years
Jasmine who's in disguise at this point
tells Aladdin that the princess isn't
allowed to go outside because ever since
the Queen was killed
the Sultan's been afraid and Jasmine's
been kept locked away Aladdin replies
that since then it feels like everyone
in Agrabah has been afraid and that the
people of the city didn't have anything
to do with the Queen's death in fact he
mentions that she was particularly loved
by everyone now it sounds like the death
of Jasmine's mother caused quite a stir
and something about it made the city's
population fearful meaning that it very
likely wasn't an accident but rather
people suspected it of being an
assassination Jasmine's mother was
originally from the kingdom of Shura bod
which in the world of aladdin is located
in south asia and her wedding to the
sultan of Agrabah was an arranged
marriage that United the two countries
to form an alliance princess Jasmine's
dual heritage means she's half South
Asian and half Arab and it's why her
outfits in the new movie or inspired by
South Asian clothing designs from her
mother's side of the family against this
backdrop in the new movie we also get a
scene where Jafar is arguing with the
Sultan that Agrabah should be forming a
military alliance with Prince Anders of
Scotland Jafar claims that Agra bars
enemies are amassing against them and
he's annoyed when Jasmine turns down the
potential marriage alliance with Prince
Anders who by the way brought cannons
with him to show off to Jasmine in a
scene that was cut from the movie the
villainous Royal vizier is keen to start
a war and he specifically mentions Shara
bad Jasmine's mother's
homeland as a target when the Sultan
tells your father that sure about his
Agri bars oldest ally and that they
shouldn't be dragged into war with them
it sounds like something happened that
broke the close bond between Agra bar
and Shara bad and that event is very
likely the suspicious nature of
Jasmine's mother's death before she
became queen of Agrabah she was probably
a princess or other royalty in her
homeland and so her murder would have
sent shockwaves in that part of the
world in the live-action film Jafar's
backstory has also built up a lot more
than in the original animation and in a
scene set in the dungeons he gives a
classic villain monologue explaining
what he's done to get where he is today
just before he dispatches one of his
minions down a well Jafar reveals that
he spent five years in a shara bad Jail
and he also talks about all the bodies
he's buried so let's connect all these
details together
first of all Jasmine's mother died in
mysterious suspicious circumstances then
we've got the fact that Jafar was
previously imprisoned in Shara bad the
South Asian Kingdom where Jasmine's
mother is from and he's now scheming to
convince the Sultan that Agrabah should
be preparing for a war with Shara bad
I'd say that it's very likely that Jafar
plotted and carried out the murder of
Jasmine's mother and that he did that
for two big reasons by getting rid of
the Sultan's wife it made your father's
rise to power much easier as it would be
simpler for him to get closer to the
king and influence him either just with
his cunning plans or with his hypnotic
snake staff on top of that Jafar seems
hell-bent on trying to start a war with
Shara bad and an effective way to
provoke their people into that would be
by killing their princess in suspicious
circumstances Jafar's personal reasons
for wanting war a twofold first he's
probably itching to get revenge on the
kingdom for incarcerating him for five
years we don't know exactly what he was
doing in Shara bad that got him locked
up but he did reveal to aladdin that
he'd been a thief so perhaps it had
something to do with how the evil
sorcerer got his magical snake staff in
addition starting such a war might
create the necessary chaos that would
enable Jafar to overthrow the Sultan
completely and take charge himself for
example if the Sultan died in the war or
if the war was to Impala with the people
of Agrabah maybe he's like Littlefinger
from Game of Thrones
and thinks he can end up on top by
climbing the ladder of chaos and there's
actually an intriguing hint as to what
Jafar might have done to Jasmine's
mother in the original animation in the
single scene where she's mentioned I
don't know where she gets it from her
mother wasn't nearly so picky Oh
Jafar my most trusted advisor
notice how just after the Sultan talks
about Jasmine's mother Jafar arrived and
his menacing shadow falls over the
Sultan knowing what we know from the new
movie I think we can read a lot more
into the original scene from the
animation now there is another
interesting maternal connection that the
new movie introduces in a little moment
where Jasmine picks up an ood and starts
playing a tune Aladdin recognizes it
immediately and tells Jasmine his mother
taught him that song and Jasmine says
her mother did too some fans have
speculated this means that Aladdin and
Jasmine's mothers are one and the same
making jasmine and Aladdin siblings
curiously there is that funny scene in
the animated movie where jasmine has to
pretend to be a lad and sister after
she's accosted for taking an apple from
a merchants cart for a hungry child you
know this girl sadly yes she is my
sister she's a little crazy no harm done
now come along sis time to go see the
doctor
well hello Doctor how are you one
possible explanation for the shed mother
theory is that Jasmine's mum had an
affair or gave birth to Aladdin before
she married the Sultan which would make
jasmine and Aladdin half brother and
sister however I think it's very
unlikely Disney would imply this as it
would make aladdin and Jasmine
relationship incestuous going beyond
Luke and Leia's kiss in Star Wars and
becoming more full-on Game of Thrones
the most likely explanation is that the
song Jasmine plays for Aladdin is quite
simply a popular one and so is known by
both their mothers another possibility
is that the song is from Shara bad and
that both their mothers have some
connection to that country in fact the
real meaning behind this moment is to
show an additional emotional connection
between jasmine and Aladdin on top of
the way in both movies each of them says
they feel trapped
you're always scraping for food and
ducking the guards you're not free
make your own choices sometimes you feel
so you're just trapped for Jazmin her
character arc in the new movie is much
more about taking forward her mother's
legacy and helping the people of Agrabah
but one point Jazmin mentions that her
mother would be unhappy at the state of
Agrabah today which is why Jazmin know
she would be the best ruler for the
kingdom originally in the animated movie
Aladdin also shared a strong emotional
connection to his mother that was
deleted from the 1992 film but was
developed further in Disney's Broadway
version of the story in particular with
a song proud of your boy which was
initially written for but ended up being
scrapped from the animated movie and to
learn more about all the other changes
in the new live-action film tap here to
watch my full video on that and there's
also a link in the video description
over the years Disney's been criticized
for its habit of killing off the mothers
of many of its characters and in Aladdin
it's not just Jasmine whose mother is
dead but Aladdin is also an orphan one
theory is that after Walt Disney felt
responsible for the death of his own
mother the studio informally adopted a
kind of no mothers policy in many of the
stories they developed do you have daddy
issues mom
more recently Ron Clements co-director
of the 1992 Aladdin said that the main
reason for dead parents and many of
Disney stories is that the original
fairytales on which the films are based
also have missing parents and it seems
that Disney may be starting to address
this issue the live-action remake seemed
to have gone out of their way to
introduce new backstories for the
protagonists missing mothers Beauty and
the Beast added a new song for the beast
called days in the Sun in which we
learned that the princes mother had died
from an illness
likewise Belle's mummies revealed to
have died from the plague soon after her
daughter's birth and there's a new song
about her called how does a moment last
forever and in Cinderella we learned
that Ella's mother also died from an
illness and that it was on her deathbed
that she asked her daughter to promise
to have courage and be kind in addition
to that although Elsa and Ana's parents
are mainly absent in frozen and
vanellope from wreck-it Ralph admits she
doesn't have a mum either some of
Disney's recent animations such as Moana
and tangled do have mothers for their
protagonists so do you like the changes
Disney
made two jasmine and Jafar in the new
Aladdin movie let me know what you think
in the comments below and subscribe to
enter my aladdin giveaway for more
details about all the other changes in
the new aladdin tapleft for my full
video on that or if you want to learn
more about Disney's live-action movies
tap right for my full playlist with more
videos on Aladdin MARY POPPINS Dumbo
Beauty and the Beast and Cinderella
thanks for watching and see you next
time yippee guy movie lovers